we are joined right now to discuss the
most important story of the day by a
young woman who is basically my de-facto
co-host whenever I fill in for Ben
because the area that she writes about
always seems to be in the news when I
fill in that would be meddling currents
the William F Buckley staff writer in
political journalism at the National
Review Institute Maddie thank you for
coming on to discuss this crazy Supreme
Court decision thanks for having me
again by the way Maddie I have to notice
last time you were on you were the
William F Buckley Jr fellow at the
National Review Institute now you are
the William F Buckley Jr staff writer so
promotion I'm just a staff writer and
yes it is a promotion now I've moved
over from the National Institute to
National Review so because Maddie Cato
as you get that promotion we are gonna
have to give a demotion to whichever
producer gave me the wrong bio here that
misstated your position but in any case
congratulations I really I really want
to get into this because the last time
you were on we talked about what signals
we were getting from the Supreme Court
about these major cases that would
radically redefine the Civil Rights Act
specifically title 7 that gave
protections because of sex to
protections based on sexual identity or
sexual preferences that that basically
would redefine sex into nothingness as
we've seen in the transgender movement
what happened today yes so the court
decided fixed to treat with that Gorsuch
and reverse bias leading with the
Liberals to to basically read the same
sex they they made the decision that the
1964 Civil Rights Act take Elena
sorry take 7 of that and the employment
discrimination law did in fact mean when
it said that you couldn't discriminate
on the basis of sex it did mean
transgender status and sexual
orientation as well which is obviously
unprecedented and will have large
sweeping effects so it's a bit of
to those of us who have been on this
issue in covering this issue and but
what are the surprising things right
though is that it sort of activism in
originalist clothings of course it has
claimed that this is the textualist
understanding which is and Samuel
Alito's words as preposterous in fact he
said it was the most brazen abuse of our
authority that he could think of so it's
pretty strong stuff Susan
so corsets let's not forget replaced
Antonin Scalia who's probably the most
prominent popularizer of originalism and
textualism in modern American history
this idea that you you should interpret
the Constitution you should interpret
laws based on what they meant
you know ordinary public meaning at the
time that they were ratified and so it's
interesting here that Gorsuch is making
the argument that at the time of the
Civil Rights Act it was it was
understood that this would protect
people on the basis of transgender
identity which at the time didn't even
exist as we know it today I mean how can
you help me make sense of that yeah it's
it is preposterous but I think the the
argument that it was closed at all from
the textual standpoint would be that you
don't normally spend too much time
looking at the subjective intentions of
legislators you look at what was
actually rested but even when you do
that I think it's very safe to realize
that people may in transgender status
because that sort of terminology did not
appear until several decades later what
so an example that would be if you look
at the Constitution as written the term
domestic violence referred to rebellions
but now we would associate that with
obviously spousal abuse and so you do
have to consider the meaning and so far
as what did the word actually mean it
became and I think it is safe to assume
but nobody was thinking of gender
identity which really nobody would have
known what that meant in 1964 and so it
really is an activist interpretation
that Gorsuch his problems but he is
claiming that he's doing just
working with the tanks which is oh it's
just don't peddle hypocrisy is the
tribute vice pays to virtue I guess and
that that's what we're seeing here with
Gorsuch pretending to be a textualist
when in fact he's passed this very
activist decision one thing on the
meaning of this word sex I noticed in
Sam Alito's excellent dissent he
includes something like nine pages of
definitions of the word sex from the
time of this passage and there's no
question that that sex did not mean what
people are saying that it meant I wonder
though I want to give Gore such a little
bit of the benefit of the doubt I mean I
think the decision was preposterous I
think it was awful I think he's dead
wrong but there is maybe a little silver
lining here which it ties into an
argument that you've seen some
conservatives make most notably
Christopher Caldwell in his new book age
of entitlement which is basically that
the Civil Rights Act which was passed
you know certainly for noble purposes
and to help real problems that people
wanted to fix but that the act itself
was much much more radical than people
realized and this is one thing I see in
Gore suchas opinion here is he keep
saying regardless of what the people who
wrote this in intended to accomplish
this is the effect that basically title
seven of the Civil Rights Act is so
broad it takes over so much power from
what you might have called the original
constitutional order that we need to
follow that to its logical conclusions
and at this point I guess fundamentally
redefine sex do you think there's
anything to that yeah I mean obviously I
think he's right in the sense that I
mean they've been trying to do this
through Congress like multiple times
they've tried to to basically get the
result that we've got today from the
Supreme Court I think I would just
reiterate though that the argument that
this is about discrimination on the
basis of sex doesn't really stand by his
own logic because for instance he's
saying that it is necessarily about sex
when you discriminate on someone with
regards to their transgender status or
sexual orientation but if you imagine
that a shock or something had a blanket
policy statement we do not hire LGBT
people LDV
keep you people need not apply they
wouldn't even necessarily know the
biological sex of those people that
they're excluding and so I think even by
his own logic his argument doesn't that
he is right of course that the fact that
this is going to have and cause social
upheaval evil it's not really the
primary concern of the court but I still
think that it is legislating from the
bench and I do think that the people who
you see coming out in support of it are
doing so because they agree with the
policy and outcome we don't necessarily
actually care very much about the fact
that this is this is a legislative event
right because as you point out here
Gorsuch is argument rests on this idea
that sure sex is different than sexual
orientation or sexual identity or
transgenderism or whatever but those
concepts necessarily involve sex meaning
if I'm a man attracted to other men then
my attraction to other men does have
some relation to my sex itself and you
know Alito's dissent he kind of rips
this apart and says look you could have
a rule that discriminates say against
homosexuals or people who identify as
the sex that they are not at that would
work across the board they would have no
reference to their own sex now the main
arguments I'm seeing here on Twitter and
in the commentary today actually have
nothing to do with the legal argument or
the constitutional argument they go
something like this
hey you awful terrible conservative why
are you so intent on discriminating
against gay people and transgender
people why are you so bigoted why do you
care about this just let it go you
hateful awful person what do you say in
response to that argument well first of
all um it's not coming from a from a
place that he is going from a place of
concern primarily for the sex base rates
and protections of women which is what
the whole on the basis of sex thing was
meant to do in the first place but to
protect women and and you know and you
know I think there is a piece by John
Birch National Review of our ethical an
April actually making the case that look
if if the Supreme Court decides with the
employees here which they have done
we really could end up in a situation
where no employer and eventually no
government institution can even
acknowledge sex differences and that
means locker room that means showers
sadly a restroom
dress cause it means the whole wall and
that could set precedent first women's
sports teams but this is really going to
be very very disruptive and the people
who are going to the biggest race for
this are women right JK Rowling actually
on another continent in another world
made this point just a week or so ago JK
Rowling the author of Harry Potter said
look I like trans people I have nothing
against trans people but women are women
and you know I don't think that men
should get to define what it is to be a
woman and I think women should have
their own spaces and be able to do
things that they want to do and she was
pilloried for saying this notably by men
by male commentators one who wrote JK
Rowling is still talking as if to say
shut up lady let me define what a woman
is and even by her own actor Daniel
Radcliffe who played Harry Potter he
said trans women are women meaning to
say men are women there was a man there
for chastising a woman for saying that
men are not women we've gone through the
looking-glass here how come ladies don't
seem to get very much care in this
discussion well it's because you know
what being a lady is just being whatever
the trans activist to say it means so I
mean the Daniel Radcliffe thing is just
preposterous because obviously he's not
actually a very good actor and so he was
his entire career
I knew just throws her under the bus
because it's the easy thing to do
yeah I mean she was absolutely right in
what she did and she's obviously been
following the debate for two years and
just really really closely and she has a
number of chargeable institutions in
Scotland actually where she lists
readers which she makes the case that
actually the relevance of sex when
you're doing medical research or
safeguard or working with children is
it's obviously really important we're
thinking about and yeah you just you
just have to walk mob just coming after
her but I think your donor first for
saying what she said anyway I like that
she's stuck by it and I'm by no means a
feminist and I probably disagree with
her on a great man
things but on this issue she seems to
make a lot of sense and I think you know
political coalition's are kind of odd
things politics makes strange bedfellows
and you're probably gonna see that in
the wake of this decision I've got to
ask you on an unrelated topic Maddie
this came up the other day and I felt
only you could offer me some expertise
on this for those of you out there who
are not familiar with accents you might
think that Maddie is from the Bronx or
from Chicago but actually she is from
Scotland and I saw this headline that
amid all the statue toppling and the
riots and the graffiti a group of
rioters has vandalized a statue of the
great Scottish King Robert the Bruce and
tagged it with the letters BLM and said
racist King now I don't know very much
about 14th century Scottish Kings but
amadee could you clear clear that up
could you maybe defend Robert the Bruce
and tell me why this is going on well I
think the problem is that nobody seems
to be when the whole stats are attacking
statue thing started there seem to be
some you know element of discriminate
discrimination and judgment and and now
you know you don't roll with the person
I'm sure he wasn't he wasn't insane in
many ways but the one that really made
me laugh was there the facing of
Churchill statue you think Churchill was
a fascist
I think so I'm really really amazing
tweet somebody tweeted who today in
response that wait till they hear about
the other guy in the face of that when
you call the man who killed Adolf Hitler
a fascist
words seem to lose all of their meaning
and I guess I guess that's kind of the
point of the Supreme Court decision
today sex no longer as a meaning man no
longer resume ting woman no longer has a
meaning but maddy you still have managed
to succeed at helping us make some sense
of the nonsense congratulations on the
promotion at National Review and I'm
sure you'll soon get a promotion to be
running this radio show because you seem
to come on every time I'm here and
really appreciate it let's see if the
culture decays any more and the court
goes crazier next time then I'm sure
well we'll have to speak with you again
Madi
you for being here hey Michael Knowles
here and the fact is a life of cigars
and scotch does not come cheap
so please be sure to subscribe to the
daily wire on YouTube because I depend
heavily on your support to continue this
wonderful Lib triggering life thanks